i am digging the festive tree in the
background danny so thank you for that
oh thank you here we are yes
yes it's here
very nice
well first of all to start with a silly
question danny for you if you had to
drop one of your previous characters
into haddonfield who do you think would
most likely survive michael myers and
who do you think would be the first to
get killed off
that is a very good question
uh
i feel like kenny powers might get
killed by michael myers i feel like he
would overestimate his charisma and
might get slashed and i feel like neil
gambie probably packs heat he would
probably
be able to survive that's that's my
guess yeah
that seems like a a good uh
a good assumption there on both of those
well cassidy for you i'm curious i mean
you've covered both politics and
religion in your recent work between the
righteous gemstones and doing the
forever purge
how representative of america do you
feel like each of those projects really
is i mean are there moments when
things feel uncomfortably close to
reality in ways that you didn't expect
um yeah that's that's a great question
something that danny's been talking
about a lot today which i really have
been enjoying listening to is sort of
the
the similarity between corporate america
and the gemstones and so and and the the
bigger the the bigger the more the how
far do you go and um
and this need to continue growing
and and being more more money more
things uh
that does feel very
you know of this time um and so that
that to me has really spoken to me you
know we shot the purge before
the pandemic
um
and even though you know the whole idea
of the border of mexico being an issue
where maybe there was going to be some
construction
was on the table um it was sort of
before all of the disruption of 2020
which was not only global pandemic but
also you know
civil rights social rights
all of that and so um
it became more pertinent after the year
when it actually came out
um but i think i think this happens a
lot i think that uh art imitates life
and life imitates art and we we tend to
be inspired by things that are happening
around us whether we're really that
aware of it or not
candy jordan told me earlier today that
the creative team is pretty open to
continuing the show for as long as
possible and you know unlike some of
your other shows where you knew where it
was going to end this show doesn't quite
feel like there's that set endpoint that
you're working toward
why do you think it is that this is a
show that still
has so much story to tell is it just
that these characters are so insane and
unbelievably fun that you could just
take them forever
you know that's definitely part of it
you know we could have all these great
ideas for the show but then we get in
here with a bunch of duds and then we're
ready to like finish it up so definitely
we have such an incredible cast that it
inspires me to want to create more and
to
push these actors into areas of like you
know that they can't see coming it's fun
to uh
to do that and uh you know i feel like
by design we tried to make it a richer
bigger world you know
uh eastbound and down was
like centered so much around kenny and
uh you know then vice principles we
opened up a little bit more by like you
know making it this two-hander and i
really wanted the opportunity to write
for something that was just much larger
and much bigger and uh and i think
because of that and because the way that
these actors have brought these
characters to life it does add this
level of richness that does feel like it
would be fun to keep digging
yeah because of you i mean how does it
feel to know that you're on a show that
could go on for a while i mean is this
the character that you're enjoying
living with
a lot um you know it's not just the
character i you know i try to choose
jobs where i i know if it goes for a
long time i won't be sick of a character
but
you can always spice that up it's it's
the family that you're in you know and
something that danny said earlier that
i've said before too that i totally
agree with is like part of it is you
want people to be talented you want them
to be able to show up and be reliable
you also want to like them as people
because we do work really long hours and
long months and we're we're together a
lot in uh and we have to be invested in
each other's lives so i would say yes
i'd be super happy to
ride this train as long as it's
it's gonna ride
it's been a while since we've gotten to
see the gemstone family so what what are
you guys most excited about with this
season with your character's
relationship this season with this crazy
wacky family
[Music]
you know as uh you know as a right on
the show i'm really excited about just
the audience kind of seeing what other
tricks this show has up its sleeve you
know from the very beginning of this uh
first episode we start to reveal like a
peek into this world that uh you know i
don't think people are going to expect
and uh
and that's what i'm excited about i'm
excited about taking the audience on
this journey and just showing them more
of what this show is capable of doing
and what these crazy people are up to is
there anything that you can't do on this
show because between you know you have
this murder mystery going on this season
you also have a
muscle man farm that i uh how i could
refer you to it
that's the best way i've heard it
described so is there anything this show
can't get away with doing
maybe space travel we we might be
pushing things too far but who knows you
know third fourth season we could be on
mars who knows uh
you know what's so funny is that you
know creating this show with all of
these different voices and with jody and
david uh everybody has their own
sensibilities and as we write the show
we love to kind of write stuff that we
know will speak to these different
creative minds individually and it does
sort of create this alchemy of this
completely
you know nuts canvas that kind of goes
from one thing to the next like bouncing
all over the place and it's by design
and it's to like make cassidy laugh when
she reads the script or make jody laugh
when he reads it or david and it's
trying to hit all these different
sensibilities and and make it feel like
it it was all planned that way
cassidy you work with a lot of really
funny people on the show and and you
also have really funny moments on the
show as well when you're working with
people like that and you're in the
moment does it feel like everybody is
coming to it from the same place and
just everyone just wants to make it the
best that it can be or does it feel like
everyone approaches the comedy a little
bit differently
i think everyone has such a different
history with comedy you know um
and and with their own experience in in
working you know i haven't had the
ability to do a lot of comedy before the
show and so this was a whole new
playground for me that i was really
stoked to be a part of i think um i
think there are certain things that we
all come to the table with that make it
work really well one of them is like
supporting each other
and um and not putting each other down
you know having it be like a really safe
space to create and bring to the table
what you want to bring to the table um
and the other one is playing the moment
for truth you know once you try and
start to make something funny it's not
funny um the things that really make me
howl and there are many a day are when
someone really comes to the table
believing what they're saying and the
humanity of it i think is what's really
funny that's written and then it's also
brought to the table by this cast
danny there's more than one mention in
these episodes of how emotionally cold
eli is do you think that eli loves his
kids do you think he loves them equally
does jesse feel like he's actually loved
by his father
you know i think that it's uh you know i
do think eli loves his kids but i think
that eli is driven by like growth in
building like i think that eli came from
nothing and the idea of building this
empire is what sort of fuels him and i
think that the casualty of that has been
his closeness with his children i i
think that like amy lee was better at uh
balancing the two things of balancing
growth and balancing nourishment uh
nurturing these these kids and i think
now that she's gone that's what eli is
lacking in is he's just left with the
growth and the business and his kids
still need
that uh
they still need that nurturing side they
still need someone who kind of
understands them as broken and damaged
as they are and i think that's part of
what eli is like facing is that he's you
know he's been solely focused on one
thing and he never realized how much
work uh was happening behind the scenes
to keep this family running
danny i love the whole bye felicia
moment you have in this it feels like
the best use of a by felicia moment that
i've seen
so
i mean
what was that like to do how long
do you think jesse has been waiting to
use that phrase
i think he's like
they're like we like playing around with
the concept that like they're not hip
you know and so jesse's jokes are a
little old
it's so uh yes i don't it was it was one
of those things that just seemed so dumb
on the page and it was fun to kind of
like portray that and then have people
getting really mad about that being said
to them like eddie's for 80s reaction in
uh adam's reaction to it just makes me
laugh so much and someone getting really
mad about that that it's just that
perfect combination of just being
completely
silly and earnest at the same time that
just like makes you shake your head
other thing that really made me laugh
was the whole gag with the the video
game chair and you know him not being
able to get out of it once he's in it
what was that like i mean that seems
like a stunt that could be so simple but
then you actually get in that moment and
you could easily get hurt so was that
more challenging than you thought it
would be
did you get a stunt double for that
chair moment i i did not i do i try to
do most of my stunts if i can
i don't know it was just something in
the writing of it that i had always just
imagined i imagined him trying to sit
down to have this like father-son moment
and it was like i was trying to look for
a riff on like the old like classic like
take the chair and spin it around
backwards and sit down in it and that
felt like that was like what jesse was
trying to do but it just failed yeah
it's a very gemstone moment i was very
amused by it
cassie i also sort of love when faced
with a gun shooting motorcycle gang that
amber is the one that really steps up
so does it feel like she's the true
badass of the gemstone family
um you know she definitely delivers and
she has some talents that she's not
gonna pull back uh when they're called
upon
but i think
i think there's lots of different types
of badassery what i love about her is
that like when push comes to shove she's
gonna show up she's gonna get it done
and that feels really good and then you
know her kind of chiding him about being
the one that actually did it makes me
laugh too
that just that whole reaction makes me
laugh all of it and it keeps coming up
which awesome
how much fun is it to have the listens
to shoot things off this season i mean
it's it's fun to see this contrast
between
you know jesse and amber sort of
thinking they're this power couple and
then this other couple coming in sort of
putting them in their place what was it
like to
have that to have eric andre it seems
like you guys were all having a lot of
fun together
you know they were blast jessica and
eric were such fun additions to the show
this season and uh
the very first thing we shot with them
was the very first time that jesse and
amber meet them so the very first thing
they shot was that sort of that moment
where they're preaching and uh and
eric is like force blasting people
through the crowd and uh
it was it was just awesome to to watch
them just inhabit this and then just to
own that stage it felt it i don't know
from sitting in a writer's room and
looking at it and to see how they
brought it to life it was it was awesome
it was gratifying and uh you know that
they uh the listens like serve as like
that's jesse and amber's aspirations you
know they want the reigns they want to
be able to do the things that the
listens are doing so it was kind of
interesting to craft like well what did
jesse and amber see themselves like to
try to craft what that is was fun
does it feel like
jesse and amber are more threatened by
the listens or by judy and bj trying to
also
find their own place and things
i think that they're more threatened by
judy and bj i think that they just want
to be friends with the listeners they
want their approval and i think with uh
with judy and bj it's just like you know
they're fighting for these rungs of the
ladder and they just don't need anybody
kind of getting in the way of that you
know they're they're they put all their
eggs in this basket of dominance and
they don't want anything challenging
that
well thank you for talking to me about
it i can't wait to see the end of the
season it's just been delightful to have
this family back so thank you
awesome thank you thank you christina